The terrorist normally means
generally to terrorize an innocent human
being. In this context, no Muslim should
ever be a terrorist.
We Muslims should only terrorize the
antisocial element, the rapist, the
robber, those who create facade. AND THE
QURAN SAYS that in Surah Anfal, chapter
number eight, verse number 60, prepare
your steed OF HORSE AND TERRORIZE THE
HEARTS OF THE antisocial element.
So, when I became popular in UK
and when the Labour Party lost and the
Conservative came to power
in 2010.
2009 was the last time I visited UK to
give a talk. I've been to UK several
times.
So, in 2010, I was supposed to give many
talks in Wembley Arena and various
places, all packed full.
So, before I land because I had a
five-year visa,
so I didn't have to get a new visa. But
before I could land into UK, when the
Labour Party lost and the Conservative
came, Theresa May was the Home
Secretary.
She says, "Who is the most famous
Muslim preacher in UK?"
So, she asked the Home Office and the
reply came, "Dr. Zakir Naik."
And they said, "Zakir Naik is supposed
TO COME AFTER A COUPLE OF WEEKS.
DON'T ALLOW HIM." I said, "What basis
can we stop him? Already we issued him a
visa.
Five-year multiple visa already issued."
She told
the counterterrorism department
that try and find something WRONG IN HIS
SPEECH
in which he's broken the UK law so we
can exclude him. We can prevent him from
coming. They scanned all my videos, they
could not find
anything.
Nothing.
In fact, in 2009,
the head of the counterterrorism
department, Charles Farr,
he sent a person
to meet me.
And he told me, "You know, Dr. Zakir
Naik? This was when the Labour Party was
in
when the Labour Party was ruling. Dr.
Zakir, we know you're very popular
amongst the Muslims.
Can you help us to guide some Muslims
who have gone astray?"
I said, "I have no problem.
I'm there to help
humanity.
I don't mind helping you under two
conditions. That you should not ask me
to do anything which is against the
glorious Quran
or the authentic Hadith of the prophet.
And I don't want your money because you
know, UK has a big budget to buy
Muslims.
They pay money and they buy you over.
And they make you things which are
against Islam. I knew about it. I said,
"As long as you don't ask me to do
anything against Quran and Sunnah, I've
no problem. I can help you."
I don't require money also, so don't try
and
attract me. And we were in coordination.
But after about 7-8 months when the
government changes, now Theresa May
who at that time was Home Secretary,
later on becomes the Prime Minister,
she wants to exclude me.
Then she sends the people from UK
Counter-Terrorism Department to meet CIA
OUTSIDE.
CHECK WITH THEM WHETHER you can get some
proof against Dr. Zakir Naik. Mashallah,
I'm on the list of CIA, FBI,
UK Department. Alhamdulillah.
I'm on the list of those people,
inshallah, who will not go to Jannah.
You'll not find them in Jannah. If you
don't follow Quran, you'll meet them
in Jahannam.
So, they said, "We don't have any proof.
Yet exclude." They said, "If you exclude
Dr. Zakir Naik, if he goes to court,
we will lose. I will handle the court."
So, in 2010,
they exclude me. I was supposed to go
for a lecture tour. And why I'm telling
you this, I'll tell you.
They exclude me and before I could leave
my country, they sent official letter
through
the High Commission
to the UK
to tell me
to tell me that I'm excluded for 3
years. And they give the reason. One of
the reason is
Dr. Zakir Naik says, "Every Muslim
should be a terrorist."
So, I'm giving you the context. What
they do, they quote out of They don't
give the full sentence. The Dr. Zakir
Naik says, "You cannot terrorize any
innocent human being." Oh, Dr. Zakir
Naik says, "Every Muslim should be a
terrorist." So, he's promoting
terrorism.
So, mashallah, we hired the best of
lawyers, one of my fan.
And my lawyers told me, "Dr. Zakir Naik,
99.9% you'll win the case. They have no
evidence." My friend who funded who paid
a million pounds, 1 million pounds. We
fought the case to the Supreme Court to
the
Court of Appeal and then went to the
European Court. He told 95% we'll lose.
This government, they're not just.
But yet, we'll show them. I was the only
Muslim who went to the Supreme Court up
to
Hague,
the European Court of Justice.
We did the case and my friend was right.
We lost the case, but we won the battle.
Our Peace TV continued. They did not go
ahead. So, the strategy